The answer is the auto save method.
It will save every few seconds.
But, how can we call
a method with a delay?
Grand Central Dispatch is your friend.
If we look at the save method
in our core data class,
the first thing you'll notice is
that it doesn't necessarily save.
It will always check the context and
see if there is anything to save, and
if there is, then it saves.
This means we only perform the save
operation with all its dependencies,
validating, deleting,
etc if it makes sense.
Now we're going to add a new
method called autosave.
We still have no idea how to
implement it, but who cares?
When you don't know what to do,
just do something and see what happens.
A good method to organize your thoughts
is to break down the complex task into
smaller ones, then write them
down as a series of comments.
We'll find out the code
we need along the way.
So let's get started.
The first part is easy,
it's just calling the save method.
The second part seems more complex,
but doc gave me a tip.
He told me to use GCD.
Check out the documentation and
see if you can find a function in GCD
that allows us to delay something.
Go on, I'll wait.
Yes, there is a function
called dispatch after.
It takes a closure and runs it after
a certain amount of milliseconds.
If we call AutoSave inside that closure,
we have what we're looking for.
A loop that saves, waits for
a certain time, and then saves again.
Just keep in mind that we're not
really saving every say five seconds.
It's even better.
We check every five seconds if
there is anything worth saving, and
only then we save.
Let's get the code for this one.
Before moving on, please make sure
to check out the documentation for
dispatch_after and dispatch_time, then
make sure you understand this code, and
then call autoSave, while passing 60,
that would be one minute
when your app launches.
This way you'll be auto
saving every one minute.